all right today uh i'm going to just
show you
about two belts how to put them on
i've seen several films on youtube
showing the correct way to put in belts
on
but i just want to explain
why i put mine on a certain way and why
i try and if i see a student
with it in my opinion incorrectly then
i tell them
to change it
i've taken an extra long white belt
to show you today
i know a lot of judo practitioners do it
this way do it this way
but in aikido i'm gonna say the reason
why
i was told about it and it it made sense
to me when i was
reasonably young so i changed it i've
never gone back so
they put it on the front they they have
it
equal
equal distance
put it on the
front of the body
would cross it over and do a normal
a normal
notch
and
the idea is for the
the tabs to
point down
it's not very good example is it there
we go
but for the tabs to
went down
okay
so that's uh that's the normal way that
you'll find 99 of the people what i want
to do is i want to show you at the back
now i'm not
done this purposely
can you see where it crosses over here
okay where it crosses over
well what happens
is in aikido
we
most people will study backward ukemi
unless you study back with your kemi you
want to come a little bit closer your
belt may get a little bit ruffled like
this
and you may be able to see that it's now
starting to deform a little bit
okay
and of course i'm doing it with my hands
but i'm
by rolling backwards and forwards the
belt can do this automatically
on your back
so
i had my belt this way
and
i went on a seminar and the teacher said
to me
would you keep rolling on a stone year
after year
and i looked a little bit strange and
thought what do you mean he said well if
you keep your belt like that as the two
cross over each other
in the end it forms a hard piece
and you perhaps won't know but in years
to come if you suffer from
back pain
you might not know you'll just think
perhaps it's a something because you're
getting older but it may be because
you're about you've been rolling on this
it's not
that's become harder and harder
and when you take the belt off of course
it's always
it's always flat
and um so you wouldn't know that it's
rolling but if you
those of you have been doing a few years
in the way i've just shown look at your
belt and see if it's starting to curve
you might know it's a slight curve
when you've been sweating
and you've been training hard you know
you go back in the changing room on a
seminar or just a heavy last training
has it started to curve a little bit
you know is this
forming
a bit of a curve
where it goes around your back
or is it
perfectly flat
depending on the material always you
know we can always make excuses and
say oh mine's soft to work anyhow
so ever since then he showed me
how to put it on
and um
i'm going to do that with the black belt
so you can see it better against the
white
so if we start with a
start with it here just
leaving the piece out
okay that you're going to want at the
end of it and you wrap it around
as you
go around
as you go around i'm going to just show
you now
the back
you see now
how nice and uh
smooth
it doesn't have any crisp class
it doesn't have any crisscross over
whatsoever
and you can roll and roll and roll on
that and it'll never form this knot i'm
talking to you about
okay then another seminar i was on with
one of my
own instructors who run his own club and
has been for years
but the instructor always wears a hakama
and we sometimes talk about progress and
should things change in aikido and even
i say no it should be kept as
traditional as you can
not modified just stick to basics but
this was one thing that i i quite liked
um watching him do it what it is is
you may be able to see it
it's a piece of felt color
and his head stitched onto his black
mouth of felt though
so
when it goes red ones
you you don't have any knots you can
pull it
you can pull it and adjust the you know
the end piece where you where you want
it to be
it's uh
it's neat tidy
when you wear your hakama it doesn't
turn i know it's not a fashion show but
it doesn't show this big knot
in your hakama
making all the pleats divide in all
different directions
you're wearing your black belt uh
everybody can see that you're on that
belt you're honoring the the respect of
that
and as you can hear
the felt code does its job really well
i was so impressed
by that that now i've done it
and um
sharing it with you
you can't uh unless you're
like myself a permanent teacher
you need two black belts if you
if you're still training so you can wear
that part when you're teaching and
you know a normal one if you want
in case you take your hand come off or i
wear that all the time
and it doesn't come undone it doesn't
matter whether you're training or not
but as i only teach nowadays
sadly due to
many joints
without arthritis osteoarthritis
it doesn't allow me to train and they
enjoy the training without many hours of
pain afterwards
anyway carrying on to that
theme
i hope it helps you
understand
if you want to keep to tradition that's
up to you
but
i think it's a good way of the health
benefits for all levels
it looks smarter the q grades
won't have it rolling up around their
back
if you're a teacher please look at your
students if you
if you uh have it done what i call the
judo way the crossover
and just see
if their belts are keeping in one place
where one's overriding the other one and
various things
okay so i think this is an improvement
for teachers and q grades
the teachers on the black belt side
and the q grades or if you're a teacher
and you've been doing it wrap over
then your hacker will protect you at the
back because it's got that sturdy piece
of either card in it or um
like a
a bone
type product in the back of the hat come
up
and
it may not bother you okay
i hope it's been of some help
thank you for watching
oh sorry
there's a piece of uh velcro
um at both ends
so i've done that
there's a piece of falcon at both ends
and obviously you have to have a
male and female
um
this is the
the hairy part
okay so they're in
certain
places
one at each end is the male
is the male the one at each end
and the females
are
on one side of the belt
and the other side of the belt
okay
so before you stick
stitch get them stitched on perhaps you
want to
just temporarily stick them to see where
they come
you need a amount coming right to the
very end of your belt
and mines i'm going to guess it
in height mines might about about two
meters in length
and um
the female is about uh
i'm going to say 70 centimeters
before it starts
and then there's a then it on the other
side there's about a 15 centimeter gap
and then
they're about 25 centimeters long each
piece
okay
so
as i say
experiment i can if people want details
please message me
they'll ask me
on the youtube site and i'll give them
exact measurements
okay again thank you for watching
and i hope it's of benefit
uh everything's about aikido shouldn't
just be about
you know
throwing people and
immobilizing people it should be about
looking at your health as well
thank you for your time